As we just discussed, in many cases,
SMART apps launch within the context of
an existing EA chart charting session where the provider,
patient and encounter are clear.
In other contexts, SMART may need to use open ID connect,
a simple identity layer on top of the OAuth 2.0 Protocol.
It enable apps to verify the identity of the end user
based on the authentication performed by the authorization server,
and obtain basic profile information about the end user.
To use open ID connect,
the app asks for the open ID scope when it request authorization,
and it will have access to a user info endpoint that exposes
user information referred to an open ID as claims.
In SMART, these include the end user's name and
their unique national provider identifier, NPI.
A 10 digit number assigned by
CMS providers that uniquely identifies them across healthcare organizations.